-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show"!
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Thank you for being here.
Well, guys,
this is very exciting --
after being canceled last year,
due to the pandemic,
the New York City Marathon
is back this Sunday!
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
It's going to be a big day.
At the starting line, runners
will take off their masks
and place them
over their nipples and --
[ Laughter ]
My favorite part of the race is
when runners cross
the finish line.
They immediately turn
into Chipotle burritos.
[ Laughter and cheering ]
Of course,
the race is 26.2 miles
and the only thing harder
than running a marathon
is listening to someone
who just ran a marathon.
[ Laughter ]
Besides the marathon,
this Sunday is also
daylight savings time.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Booing ]
The one thing Americans
can all agree on --
hating daylight savings time.
[ Laughter and applause ]
No one quite likes it, yeah.
It's that magical trade where
we swap one extra hour of sleep
for five months
of seasonal depression.
I think that's nice.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
Seriously, what's more fun
than picking up your kids
from school in total darkness?
[ Laughter ]
"Papa, is that you?"
[ Whispering ]
Come closer to my voice.
[ Laughter ]
Well, get this --
I saw that New York City
has extended
its $100 vaccine incentive
to kids ages 5 to 11.
[ Oohs and cheering ]
A hundred bucks.
Meanwhile, the smart kids
were like, "Yeah, make it $200,
or we start doing
our own research."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Kind of sets a bad precedent.
I mean, every time you
ask your kid to take medicine,
they're going to be like --
[ New York accent ]
"You forgetting something, pal?"
[ Laughter ]
That's right, after getting
the money, parents said,
"Now, don't waste it."
And kids said,
"Oh, like how you bought
a $2,000 Peloton?"
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
I'm going to leave you
in the darkness.
Some more COVID news --
today, Apple began
dropping mask mandates
at some of its U.S. stores.
Some think it's
because of the declining cases,
but others say it's just
because Apple's
about to release the iMask Pro.
[ Laughter ]
[ Rimshot ]
[ Applause ]
"That'll be $3,000."
[ Laughter ]
But Apple says safety
is still their top priority.
Then, they went back to letting
hundreds of strangers
rub the same iPad.
[ Laughter ]
[ Changes accent ]
"Ooh, this one looks nice!"
[ Laughter ]
Don't lick it.
Meanwhile, I saw that Uber's
bringing back UberPool,
for the first time
since the pandemic began.
[ Booing ]
It's great news,
if you love the bus,
but dream of something
more intimate.
[ Laughter ]
Some entertainment news --
today,
Marvel's "Eternals"
finally hit theaters.
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
Marvel fans haven't been this
excited since two seconds ago,
when the last Marvel movie
came out.
[ Laughter ]
"Eternals" is
about a young poet trying
to find her voice
in postwar Europe.
Just kidding. It's about
laser-shooting mutants.
[ Laughter ]
Apparently, it's the first
Marvel movie with a love scene.
[ Ohs and cheering ]
It's a little awkward.
Basically, the guy thinks
he's Iron Man,
only to find out he's Ant-Man.
[ Laughter and ohs ]
You know what I'm saying?
-Oh.
-Hey, I heard
about a Colorado man
who set his mother's house
on fire
while trying to get rid
of cobwebs with a blowtorch.
[ Laughter ]
When his mom said,
"Did he get the cobwebs?"
He was like,
"Technically, yes."
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
a Southwest Airlines employee
created a dress out of 800
lost luggage zipper pulls.
[ Laughter ]
When she asks her husband
to zip her up,
he finishes
about six hours later.
Guys, the NASCAR Cup
Series Championship
airs this Sunday,
right here on NBC,
on your television!
[ Cheering and applause ]
We love NASCAR.
Now, at the end of the series,
they give out an award
for Most Popular Driver,
but they also give out
some other awards as well.
I'll show you what I mean.
It's time for
"Tonight Show Superlatives."
Here we go.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-♪ Tonight Show ♪
♪ Superlatives ♪
♪♪
-Now, our first driver is...
He was voted...
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
"I go fast around the corners."
[ Laughter ]
Up next, we have...
[ Awws and applause ]
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"Wow!"
-"Is this a dream?"
-"Oh, my gosh!
Where's my milk?"
-"Santa!"
[ Laughter ]
Next up, we have...
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-♪ Zaltrex ♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Scat singing funk ]
♪♪
Up next, we have...
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh,
because he's a little teapot.
-Yeah.
They call him Little Teapot.
-He's both short and stout.
-[ Southern accent ]
Here comes Little Teapot
around the corner.
-[ Matching accent ] Coming
right here, short and stout.
[ Imitates vuvuzela blast ]
Brrr!
-Up next, we have...
-Ooh!
-He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"You only have rhombuses?
Oh, I'll come back."
[ Laughter ]
Next up is...
-Ooh!
-He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"I'm going to fight for you."
Up next, we have...
[ Audience awws ]
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"You are full of beans."
-"Oh, you."
[ Laughter ]
Do you like it? "Oh, you."
-"Yeah."
-Next up, we have...
-Ooh.
-He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next up, we have...
-Oh.
-He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Not today, not ever!"
[ Cheering and applause ]
And, finally, we have...
He was voted...
[ Cheering and applause ]
There you have it.
Those are your "Superlatives."